السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز
والاخبار من الجزيره قال مصدر فلسطيني
للجزيره ان الانفجارات التي وقعت على حدود
قطاع غزه ناجمه عن اطلاق قذائف باتجاه
دبابات اسرائيليه خان يونس واضاف المصدر
الفلسطيني للجزيره ان القذائف اجبرت
الاليات هي الاسرائيليه على الانسحاب من
المنطقه التي توغلت فيها بخان يونس
في المقابل قال المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان الدبابه اطلقت عددا من
القذافي على موقع تابع لحماس شرق خان يونس
وذلك عاقبه تفجير فلسطينيين عبوه ناسفه
قرب قوه عسكريه في المنطقه الامنيه عند
الحدود مع قطاع غزه
اعرب بيان للاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلق بالغ
ازاء تزايد العنفي في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله وداع البيان القدس الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين الى تهدئه الموقف والامتناع
عن الاجراءات التي تزيد مستوى التوتر واكد
ان المستوطنات غير قانونيه بموجب القانون
الدولي
وفي الضفه شيع اهالي مدينه جنين ومخيم
عسكري في نابلس جثامينا سته شهداء سقطوا
برصاص جيش الاحتلال في مخيم جنين
قالت مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه الامريكيه
ان ايران اقتربت بشكل خطير من صنع قنبله
نوويه واضافه النيران زادت من وتيره
برنامجها النووي واجرت بحوثا وانشطه تطوير
تقربها من انتاج المواد اللازمه لصنع سلاح
النووي
عرب بيان فرنسي بريطاني الماني عن القلق
اذا يعلن ايران تركيب المزيد من اجهزه
الطرد المركزي كما عبر الاتحاد الاوروبي
عن قلقه العميق وصفه بالتصعيد المتسارع
لبرنامج ايران النووي وحتى طهران على
العوده الفوريه الى التزاماتها
قال المندوب الروسي لدى المنظمات الدوليه
في فيينا انه لا تزال هناك فرصه لاستعاده
الاتفاق النووي عبر المفاوضات واعتبر ان
كل المخاوف التي جرت تعبير عنها بشان
البرنامج النووي الايراني يمكن تبديدها
بسهوله اذا عادت الاطراف المعنيه
في جورجيا تعمل وشرطه على تفريق متظاهرين
تجمعوا امام مقر البرلمان في العاصمه
ووقعت اشتباكات عنيفه قرب البرلمان بين
محتجين علما يعرف بقانون العملاء الى جانب
والشرطه ويقول المعارضون لمشروع القانون
انه اداه لترهيب وسائل الاعلام والمنظمات
غير الحكوميه وقد خرجت هذه المظاهرات بعد
ان صدق نواب الحزب الحاكم على مشروع
القانون في قراءته الاولى هذه مشاهدينا
الصور مباشره تاتينا من العاصمه الجورجيه
بيليسيه وتظهر بان هناك
المظاهرات تزال مستمر حتى هذه اللحظات من
الليل وقد دعى المتحدث باسمي وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه الحكومه الجورجيه الى
احترام حريه التظاهر
اعلن رئيس ميليشيا الروسيه سيطره قوته
بشكل كامل على شرق باخمه الاوكرانيه من
جانبه حذر رئيس الاوكراني من ان سقوط طبخ
قد يمكن الروس من الذهاب الى ما هو ابعد
من المدينه في السويد يبحث زرعوا الدفاع
الاتحاد الاوروبي تسريع دعم كيف استعدادا
لتصيد مرتقب خلال الربيع وكان وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني قد طلب وزراء الدفاع الاوروبيين
بدعم بلاده عسكريا بانظمه دفاع جوي
قالت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه ان مجلس
الشيوخ الفرنسيه اقر مشروع القانون يرفع
سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 ياتي هذا
التطور بعد مظاهرات واضرابات مستمره
وواسعه احتجاجا على قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي اقترحه الرئيس
انما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]